hey what's going on is Bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday October 16 2017 what's going
on how are ya
Oh freckles is in a good mood
he is in a great mood what up what a
[ __ ] great win a gutty great win by
the new england patriots
non-controversial nothing to complain
about I don't understand what the Jets
ago it was clearly a that the guy looked
like you ever see when like people join
the Mafia and they got to hold that
little candle like he was doing that for
one hand or another clearly not a catch
I mean oh he caught it then it was a
fumble I'm [ __ ] with you you Green
[ __ ] I don't get it either that looked
like a touchdown to me and you know what
sucks I wish that they called it a
touchdown cuz then it would have been
tied up and I could have watched Tom
Brady go right down the field and break
your [ __ ] green hearts once again the
[ __ ] nerve you jet fan stacked like
you got [ __ ] out of a victory what you
got [ __ ] would you know what you've
got the end of the refs gave you mercy
they gave you some mercy let's just put
them out of their [ __ ] misery come on
man
think how many you [ __ ] fair we're the
best it's because of that call we'll be
able to go down there and get to your
[ __ ] green and white hyeyeon day
whatever the [ __ ] it is you're driving
right and left the stadium early because
of that wonderful accurate call I'm
[ __ ] with you guys I'm just being a
douche I don't I don't get it either
I don't I I wish I was at Scholl I wish
was called a touchdown they don't have
been tied up would have an exciting game
miss exciting game but you know add to
the drama tie score who's gonna win the
Jets who the Patriots have used as a
[ __ ] blow-up doll for the last 15
years this sick of it this sick of
losing to the they're sick of losing to
leaves to live with Patriots these
Patriots of the Lakeland this is what I
love you know was my favorite part of
that game was when the Jets scored the
first touchdown to go up seven enough
and
if you can look at the highlight look in
the crowd - dude the jet fan with the
he's got the jersey on he's holding his
smartphone and he's given double fingers
that like one of the new england
patriots defensive backs like i got'em
it as a sports fan I know what that
feeling is like you know I haven't known
it for a good 15 years 16 17 years but I
ever you know the first 32 years of my
life 34 years all you know depending on
the sport was what that's what it was we
just did not win that I I saw myself
back when the Patriots would always lose
to the Dolphins a Dan Marino like we
we'd finally sack them somehow
finally sack him and he'd be on the
ground I'd be like [ __ ] yeah like we
finally got him so I took that as a a
nod of respect to the Patriots as much
as the plus the guy he's a real fan man
if he's if he gives a [ __ ] that much so
anyways I I'm out here I am I am Manik
right now because I am in a a mild
depression I miss my family so much I'm
gonna try to I don't get him to fly out
here this week this is [ __ ]
ridiculous I got a I got to see my kid
one way I know that I see my kids so I
just been I just been [ __ ] watching
sports everybody that's all I've been
doing I mean I know I always do it but
like I literally was like what am I
gonna do on Saturday you know they don't
shoot on weekends what am I gonna do out
here I don't know what the [ __ ] to do
with myself so I drove three hours up in
three hours back I went to that
Tennessee volunteer game against the the
South Carolina Gamecocks msec accent
honey I gotta be swapping some paint I
went up there and it was it was [ __ ]
awesome it was a great Drive you know if
you're comedian you gotta love driving
after a while and he also gotta love
driving by yourself you know if you're
if you're comedian you don't like doing
that you usually end up getting an
acting career or a writing career or you
just [ __ ] quit the business I don't
know what it is but I've always enjoyed
it so I had a great time
an update I never drove from Atlanta
into Chattanooga up to [ __ ] in Knoxville
I want to see what it looks like and I
was driving up there it was a 12 noon
game so I didn't leave it like [ __ ]
quarter to 8:00 in the morning but this
is good cuz it's gonna go all the way up
there it's gonna be three hours for the
game and three hours to drive back by
the time I get back I can still do a
spot down the street at the club
Ian Edwards is gonna be down there one
of the best [ __ ] comedians in the
country that nobody not enough people
know about all right like I looked up
the other day I looked up this guitarist
I found this guitarist that you know was
for the while was known as the greatest
guitarist nobody ever heard of like
Danny gotten or something like that I
gotta get his [ __ ] name right the
guy's unbelievable he's I mean
unfortunately he's dead but uh you know
the guy was she was like a [ __ ] jeah
Danny Gatton GA tto n looked that guy up
and there's a thing when he plays Austin
City Limits where I'm gonna be next week
I'm at the new one not the one he was at
they say he plays a song will they say
with a beer can he actually does it with
a beer bottle I've seen people do it the
slide and all that but watch what
happens because the beer gets all over
the neck starts you know there's beer in
there so it starts fizzing up it gets
all over his fretboard and then he puts
a towel over the fretboard to dry it off
while continuing to play I've never seen
I mean I've seen a lot of tricks it was
[ __ ] amazing so Ian Edwards telling
you you got to see you got to see that
guy that it's just there's something
wrong with that [ __ ] business that
more people doesn't don't know who that
guy is so like I got to go down and go
see him do a set and plus not only that
that'll take up my whole [ __ ]
Saturday then I'll stay out late enough
I come home fall asleep boom done right
so anyway so I'm trying I'm driving up
to northern [ __ ] and George you're into
southern Tennessee and there's all this
[ __ ] traffic so the robot lady and my
phone starts talking to me creeping me
out telling me there's a quicker way
it's just like well how do you have time
to
pay attention to me who are you but
thank you so I get off the [ __ ] Road
and I'm driving up north there and I
went by this [ __ ] house you know
those houses well they somebody just has
like 20 old cars sitting in the front
yard this [ __ ] lunatic had like 30
not cars he had riding mowers now like
the landscape-level ones like the ones
like your dad had you know and you try
to [ __ ] you know steal the keys to
take it out or whatever you'd run over a
friend of yours and he'd lose a foot or
whatever you know that type of [ __ ]
Jesus what's going on out here
oh Christ is it gay pride parade still
going on there's anything on fire they
had the gay pride parade out here went
right by the hotel yesterday and uh you
know it's [ __ ] funny there's always
one guy who has to just ruin it you know
what I mean there's always one guy that
just ruins it for everybody else like
you know sports fans are cool and then
just one douche bag and a Panthers game
has to turn around and blast a 63 year
old guy in the face not once not twice
not three times of leyte four [ __ ]
times
at least they caught the guy do that guy
he's looking I think it's some serious
jail time serious [ __ ] jail time you
know the first to maybe get some [ __ ]
you know Andy Griffith Laura going well
you know emotions were running high and
that guy he she had a lot of names
calling to him going back and forth you
know he just whoa you got a little bit
hold on account right maybe he couldn't
keep I don't know what just get him a
couple like a month in jail or something
it's the fact that they broke it up and
he came back for those last two brutal
ones Jesus Christ and I hope old people
learned something out there okay yeah
you know as much as it hurts your lower
back you got to keep that head moving
can't you can't just be a stationary
target
[Music]
he's goddamn old people you know it's
like they give you if you want to talk
[ __ ] you got to move your [ __ ] head
I'm sorry anyways this [ __ ] guy he
had like 30 riding lawnmowers sitting in
his front yard I was doing like 70 miles
an hour when I drove past it and I
wasn't gonna stop because I was worried
I wasn't gonna get to the game of time
and it was [ __ ] hilarious the ironic
part was like the grass had all grown up
around him like this front yard needed
to be mowed but he couldn't mow it
because he had said you know we had all
the [ __ ] tractors do you get it
people there's something there's a joke
in there somewhere I just don't know
where anyways I ended up getting up
there to the stadium a Tennessee game
place I always wanted to go to and it
was it was [ __ ] awesome and not only
that as a freckled borderline albino
[ __ ] I picked the perfect row I called
up StubHub and I told him I said I'm an
old man who gets sunburned I want to be
in the lower deck right above the roof
of the oh you know of the upper deck and
the lays like okay actually for once I
looked at the the stadium map you know
and you know so amazing I know you don't
give a [ __ ] you just you just sold a
ticket to a [ __ ] World Cup game now
I'm now I'm and I brought you into
Tennessee you know you know ain't no way
you're at so I went with row 57 and it
was the perfect row it was the last
[ __ ] row that the Sun didn't touch
because I was on the visitors side if
you ever go to the stadium the Sun
creeps up the visitors side it goes down
on the home side so it creeped all the
way up to row 56 and at the end of the
game it was it was on like from like
mid-calf down I [ __ ] it I nailed it I
mean actually if I did 58 it would have
been perfect but um it was just it was
an awesome time one of the biggest
stadiums I believe it's the fifth
largest stadium as far as the amount of
people that it holds and it's an
old-school stadium [ __ ] I didn't even
have the nerve to go in the bathroom I
just saw this door that look like a
[ __ ] closet door and I was like
there's a bathroom in there there's no
way there's not piss troughs in there
and I am
peeing in a [ __ ] piss trough I'm not
doing it and I got to tell you when
you're on the lower level and you're
walking through that you feel like
you're in a bunker is if you're
claustrophobic I wouldn't do it I got
all these great pictures I got a post a
man that just like the stadium is so
[ __ ] cool and I have to go there you
know they have a decent team I want to
go there when to an SEC game at night
under the lights when it [ __ ] matters
underrated city Knoxville underrated
Chattanooga Tennessee is the [ __ ] you go
to Nashville Nashville is like Austin
Texas where it's just everybody's moved
there or Atlanta everybody's just they
just [ __ ] it overcrowded and the two
great cities so I went there you know
the [ __ ] bands playing you know there
wasn't a bunch of screaming yelling they
didn't have giant flat-screen [ __ ]
TVs and explosions and [ __ ] it was just
it was like the old school just go into
a game there was a hilarious guy in my
section which there always is you just
can't hear him now when you go to a game
there was this [ __ ] big fat - - there
was a lot of fatties at the game
Tennessee what's going on up there lay
off the [ __ ] barbeque Jesus Christ I
can tell why you guys love those [ __ ]
checkered overalls holds you [ __ ]
beer belly really nicely
this guy was [ __ ] hilarious he looked
like he was dressed like herb Harlech
except was all Tennessee gear and he was
so [ __ ] amped up for the game and he
was getting the section going and he
would always get right up to the border
line is this guy [ __ ] nuts and then
he'd look at him he'd have this
shit-eating grin on his face like
laughing at himself knowing that he was
nuts that he was getting this amped up
for the game but um it was a great game
and I stayed till the end like my mother
taught me and it came right down to the
last play I [ __ ] you know I
videotaped it while I looked over so I
could watch it you know live and not
look at it through my screen and it
looks like the guy had a chance wouldn't
look like wooden right through his his
fingers and it didn't work what happened
then I drove [ __ ] back I came down
here I went down to the Laughing Skull
and I got to watch the great Ian Edwards
just [ __ ] blew me away I'm telling
you right now if you get a chance to see
that guy live
got to do it you got to do it before it
blows up hung out with him some of his
friends got a grilled cheese sandwiches
some french fries a late night out Jesus
just eating like a fat chick on prom
night I'm depressed all right [ __ ]
dealing with this [ __ ]
so anyways so that was that day so then
Sunday comes along I'm like well how am
I gonna kill this day a loneliness and
it's like oh [ __ ] the Atlanta Falcons
are home they got a [ __ ] home game
holy [ __ ] they're playing the Dolphins
[ __ ] Jay Cutler I'm gonna go see I've
already saw them play against the Rams
this you know the Chargers this year
I'll go down and go check up and
evidently the the [ __ ] Falcons have
this new dome stadium that's gonna be
unbelievable so I was like all right
I'll go to this [ __ ] game last time I
was here was in [ __ ] 2004 I saw
Michael Vick back when he was drowning
the dogs and nobody knew the most
electrifying [ __ ] football player I
ever saw every time he went out of the
pocket the whole stadium stood up like
it was the last play of a championship
game and a Hail Mary was coming place
would go crazy right so I my garment
Goldie I don't have a ticket I'll be
there I'll Scout particular sit at the
top of the stadium who gives a [ __ ] so I
get over there and there's like no
scalpers and I'm like what the phone oh
I didn't do the gay pride parade I
walked through the gay pride parade I
gotta get back to the one guy who ruins
it so it's typical gay probably parade
bunch of people [ __ ] rainbows on
their faces you know a couple guys
walking around in high heels shoes gay
pride parade everybody's having a good
time what's not to [ __ ] like right
there's always the one dude who has to
ruin it this [ __ ] jerk-off is
standing there on the side of the road
he has like a [ __ ] giant dick and
balls like balloon animal that was is
like three-quarters the size of his body
this giant pink erect [ __ ] dick with
balls and it's just like dota these kids
here
this [ __ ] what is wrong with you is what
blows my mind is you're able to do that
at the gay pride parade I'm trying to
think of a parade that I could go to
with a giant inflated vagina
with kids around and it's just in public
I just don't think he could do it but
anyways hey hey I'm trying to be
progressive
god bless this guy with his giant dick
and balls like [ __ ] twisted up
balloon in him I actually had to wonder
if that was like a plant from the
religious right to show all gay people
represent them as like they just see
sexually deviant [ __ ] people you know
like you always see those conspiracy
theories that they have you know
whenever there's a peaceful
demonstration they send somebody down
there they throw a rock through a window
just to get everybody going to start
rioting so that you know all the people
protesting get to be lumped in with that
one douche so whatever so I totally
judged this guy with his giant [ __ ]
balloon twisted dick and balls going
what a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
well how the [ __ ] was this guy raised
blah blah blah blah blah smash cut to me
not even 20 minutes later when I find
there's no scalpers and I go up to the
[ __ ] Wilco one of the ticket windows
they say they're sold out and the only
way to get a ticket is I have to go on
my phone to Ticketmaster and I have no
idea how to do this
I voted Computers I don't know I don't I
just I'm bad with the [ __ ] you know what
I mean you know like like me trying to
figure out this [ __ ] is like ask
somebody like somebody tone-deaf just
sing a [ __ ] song you know he's just
you can't do it right so could you tell
I got a text message in the middle of
that I didn't even finish off what have
a funny thought I was trying to have
their mildly amusing thought I was
trying to have so anyways if I can get
over the stadium and now I got to figure
out this tic Ticketmaster thing so I
walk away like it just like Kherson my
[ __ ] brains out [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ] [ __ ] Buck Rogers [ __ ]
[ __ ] a [ __ ] walking by kids and [ __ ]
and I see parents looking at me like
dude what the [ __ ] and in the way in the
back of my head is that voice of reason
hey Bill tell there's no reason to hit
this to get this crazy come on
reel it in there's children here and I
just did the [ __ ] demon in me just
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] right so I
sit down like a little [ __ ] boy like
a little like the little [ __ ] baby
that I am Jesus Christ bill download the
[ __ ] app and figure it out trying to
figure out it's not working I'm just
every time I wouldn't work I'm like dude
what the [ __ ] I would literally yell
that loud people walking by looking like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with that guy
right and finally some 20-somethings
security kid came walking by with his
yellow coat I was just like dude I'm an
old bastard I don't know how to do can
you help me out this and he was just
like yeah I just click on this click on
this click on that again alright there
it is there's a ticket and I'm just
sitting here look at it say I'm like
this is a ticket he's like yeah it's a
ticket I go what do I do and he's just
laughing he goes just bring your phone
and then they scan it I'm like this is
gonna work and he's like yeah so now I'm
standing in line I am so little faith
that technology is gonna it's gonna work
for me all I could think of was Midnight
Express in the beginning of the movie
when the dude is the drugs take to him
I'm like I'm gonna get this isn't gonna
work they're gonna they're gonna get
like they're gonna toss me out of the
[ __ ] stadium and I'm gonna be out
this whatever 100 bucks or whatever I
paid for this ticket and it went up I
they scanned it and it worked and I was
like wow how the [ __ ] it worked then I
was just like well what was it with a
how do I add this to my all my stack of
tickets do I gotta [ __ ] put my phone
in there now do I take a picture of it
and then print it out on my printer and
then that's the ticket I don't get it
so anyways I go into this stadium and
Jesus Christ I'm telling you you got to
[ __ ] go to this stadium this is the
best NFL stadium out there it is like I
mean my top of the new ones before that
I mean you got to go Cowboys Stadium
even though that TV is just so [ __ ]
big and obnoxious it's actually stupid
they took the TV out of there the
Cowboys I think they would like you know
what I mean the Cowboys Stadium is like
I don't know you ever see like a
beautiful woman that's just absolutely
shit-faced and she's got
like [ __ ] lipstick on her teeth and
red wine breath and just like oh my god
she's good you know and she's a ten but
you like get the [ __ ] away from me right
that's what the Cowboys stayed that's
what that TV is just [ __ ] up the whole
stadium and the Seahawks have a great
stadium even though they're cheating
making the crowd sound louder than it is
but anyways speaking of cheaters the
[ __ ] Atlanta Falcons who got caught
pumping crowd noise in so I'm at this
cheaters right
it's [ __ ] breathtaking it's one of
the cleanest design sickest [ __ ]
unlike Jerry Jones is gonna be upset if
he I'm sure you see God on his private
plane you don't get Botox injections on
the way over there I'm sure when he
walked in there these goddamn
[ __ ] right he's got damn
[ __ ] he's probably [ __ ] I
don't know god help the woman that he's
banging that weekend Jerry I just sort
of said what I'm doing wrong oh shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] he's taking out everything
on her dude that stadium is [ __ ] I
felt like I was in a spaceship it was
[ __ ] awesome I'm just like you know
it was great I missing my family I'm
down there I'm just like all good good
now I'm in a good mood and dude I am
sitting at the top of the stadium and
it's still [ __ ] awesome I mean I was
so [ __ ] high up on the place what
happened and he could kind of just just
watch the whole defense you know I love
doing that when you go to a game when
you sit up high just watching the
defense you kind of have like in your
peripheral where the balls going and
just trying to see in alignment if they
come down and try to pick up a
linebacker or something like that or
like you know try to figure out which
receivers open I'm a nerd I love doing
that [ __ ] however I got to tell you
something that the experience of going
to that game I get that the NFL cares
but Jesus Christ I think the NFL has
kind of forgot that Sports is like an
escape you know what I mean especially
now with social media and all that [ __ ]
you just can't get away with all the
[ __ ] just all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
go my god this this city just got hit by
a [ __ ] hurricane in this video and we
got Puerto Rico then white wires and why
aren't they getting help
there you know what I mean all these
veterans they're coming back to commit
suicide blah blah blah all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's just it's [ __ ] brutal so
what do you do you need to shut it off
for a while you go to a [ __ ] game but
this was the experience at the Atlanta
game
first of all dude it was so [ __ ] loud
in there
and just take all this with a grain of
salt because I'm an old [ __ ] all right I
get in it was so [ __ ] loud um they
have these giant flat screens up at the
top all going around in a circle and
they're amazing I don't think that
they're too big and they're not hanging
down in your face so they're not really
that distracting or anything but it was
like the cheerleaders came out and they
[ __ ] would play this music I felt
like I was in an ac/dc concert it was
that [ __ ] loud and all of a sudden
like Sam jacks no no no wait before that
wait before that little John and another
Atlanta rapper I mean I'm white as [ __ ]
I don't know who the [ __ ] this guy is
I'm sure he's great whatever they did
like a public service announcement on
fan behavior all right which I'm sure is
based off the one [ __ ] who [ __ ]
punched the 63 year old guy four times
in the face so now we got to get a
lecture on how to be human beings and
they just sit there go like you know
don't uh don't you know don't be
discourteous to the people next to you
it was funny was really bland copy and
watched a little John trying to like add
something to it was hilarious and they
at one point they say don't say anything
racial I believe that's what they were
saying it was so loud it was echoing and
I couldn't hear it and then there was
something about not saying anything
politically charged no it's like where
the [ __ ] am I right now who the [ __ ]
gives about gives a [ __ ] about politics
I'm at a football game who gives a [ __ ]
I'm trying to think back when I was a
kid when I went to a Bruins Patriots
game or something like that you know in
the ladies I don't ever remember anybody
yelling out [ __ ] about Mike Dukakis
versus George Bush Senior anyways let me
get back to this guy real quick
yeah so think they said today this this
whole [ __ ] thing happen and then the
[ __ ] cheerleaders come out and then
playing some [ __ ] crazy loud song man
yeah yeah yeah well happy we playing all
this [ __ ] DJ [ __ ] they're out there
dance and shaking their ass I literally
had my fingers in my ears like Jesus
Christ I should have brought earplugs to
this [ __ ] thing and then out of
nowhere
Sam Jackson starts [ __ ] screaming at
everybody to get up something about the
heartbeat you know we gotta [ __ ] do
this first of all it's like Sam Jackson
you from New York when did you start
giving a [ __ ] about the Falcons you know
what I mean I mean you would think he
had enough Capital One money to take a
[ __ ] weekend I think guys in star
wars he is like Capital One he's
everywhere you want to be right his
[ __ ] guys screaming and he's doing
the whole [ __ ] like it was something
about a heartbeat he'd yelled some Chevy
gotta [ __ ] that out there and then
this giant heart people go go go
deafening and then they cut to like you
know and when it when it was like
beating that would cut to like an
Aladdin planet Falcon like thumping his
chest mean-mugging yeah good good I'm
just so good dude I'm not playing I
don't need to get this amped up
screaming and [ __ ] yelling it was so
loud and so [ __ ] distracting that I
didn't even notice that the [ __ ]
players had taken the field and what
alerted me that the players had taken
the field was after Capital One Sam
Jackson had stopped screaming and the
heartbeat had ended all of a sudden I
hear a locomotive train horn it just
goes loud as [ __ ] and they kicked the
ball off so it was the cheerleaders
daddy I can't Sam Jackson get the [ __ ]
up you [ __ ] you know and then
and after all of that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
ball just goes out of the back of the
end zone dad and then the announcer just
goes touch back Atlanta
[Laughter]
so I burst out laughing and the lady
next to me starts laughing and I look at
her like she saw what I saw and thought
it was funny and she was just laughing
because I made her uncomfortable because
I was at the game by myself and I just
bursted out laughing so I think I came
off as like a crazy person
alright and then then I and then and
then all this [ __ ] starts happening okay
and intertwined with all of this is like
the Trail of Tears that for some reason
the NFL I don't know what they're trying
to do I understand that there's a lot of
people suffering in the world I get it I
do benefits I give to charities you know
I I try to do my [ __ ] part I don't
know what the solution is I don't know
why we can't get along I don't know why
there's disease and all that but we but
what we do have is we have music and we
have sports and it's a way to kind of
get away from it right this is what the
[ __ ] I saw at the game okay the game
starts and they have a veteran who's
missing a leg runs out with the flag
okay which is uplifting but also
depressing he lost his leg I'm like ah
[ __ ] these [ __ ] kids man this whole
[ __ ] generation generations at this
point we got to be in the second
generation that's over there fighting
[ __ ] wars why why did we try to solve
things this way it's poor [ __ ] guy
man he's losing mister he's lost a leg
all right so I'm thinking about people
losing limbs in the war it lady goes out
the leg goes out to sing the national
anthem now it was so [ __ ] loud when
they announced I forget what her cause
was there was some sort of ribbon and it
was cancer related so we got the
one-legged vet and then I'm like I
[ __ ] a veteran sigh Jesus Christ God
how do we get out of this [ __ ] war
right I'm thinking about that then I'm
thinking about people with cancer and
then the coin toss they bring this cute
little boy out nine-year-old kid or
something who survived bone marrow
cancer and then I start thinking oh my
god what if my
that's horrible what if my kid ever got
cancer how would I handle that what
would I do
oh my god if my kid died I'd [ __ ]
kill myself
I stopped thinking suicidal [ __ ]
thoughts here alright then the [ __ ]
game starts doctor back Atlanta right
there played all this [ __ ] loud his
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm trying to shake off
all the misery of the world that I've
been reminded of like five different
examples and then out of nowhere this
they show this won't they show this guy
on this screen and then they show this
woman who's married to the guy and she's
now a widow because the dude died in
Afghanistan and I'm like oh my god she
lost her husband oh that poor woman
that's [ __ ] terrible and then they
cut to her wearing an Atlantic Falcons
jersey with their two kids who are now
fatherless wearing the jersey smiling
and waving at this giant [ __ ]
flatscreen and all I'm thinking is like
those [ __ ] kids are gonna grow up
without a father
second out it's really a right I'm just
like what the what is going on here it
was one of the most depressing dude it
was like nine minutes left in the first
quarter and in case you missed the
veteran running out with one leg they
[ __ ] showed that again and all I
could think at that point it's like what
is the halftime show gonna be am I gonna
watch somebody die in an iron lung well
their family members are holding hands
crying and then the PA announced to be
like yeah that's right look at it look
at that misery do you people realize how
lucky you are
you don't have to spend your life and
your own personal suffering hey Lincoln
exhaling make Jesus Christ NFL why stop
there how about every time they [ __ ]
throw the ball you show me the cow that
was slaughtered so they could have this
skin any time they shoot t-shirts into
the crowd why don't you just show me the
[ __ ] sweatshop labor that put it
together you know what it is caring is a
great [ __ ] thing but how about you
pick a cause rather than they dig
I mean what did they show in the thymine
I left I left with like five minutes
left in the second quarter it was just
like you know what this is a great
stadium I want to be here with a friends
and [ __ ] and I'm already depressed that
I'm on the [ __ ] Road I'm missing my
family I came here to get away from that
sadness and I've been reminded that I'm
kind of being selfish because these
people have way bigger sadness than I do
and somewhere in all of that I saw a
balloon [ __ ] dick and balls twisted
[ __ ] balloon animal while kids were
walking by I'll tell you it was a hell
of a day you know so I actually and I
saw that the Jets were [ __ ] coming at
the Pats and I was like why don't I just
go sit in a [ __ ] bar and watch this
thing this is the other thing too like I
I just I just don't 100% buy that the
[ __ ] NFL truly cares that much you
know what I mean cuz you know they got
busted whenever they show a veteran in
the crowd we have one of our heroes here
ba ba ba ba ba ba the whatever branch of
the service they're showing they have to
pay the NFL they considered a
recruitment video like it like a
commercial
I heard they recently adjusted it I
don't know but what the [ __ ] right yeah
how much [ __ ] money do you have to
make so I believe the owners
individually I believe that they all
care about these causes I'm sure all of
them have had you know friends or
whatever fighting and wars have been
touched you know unfortunately had a
family or family or a friend that got
cancer or something like that but I
really have to believe that just because
it is a corporation and the way that
they handled and the way that they've
handled their players you know what I
mean but all the brain damage and [ __ ]
and they just [ __ ] ignored it
allegedly after they knew about it and
then when they did the class-action suit
against the NFL they basically gave
every player like 800 or a thousand
bucks that just comes off like a PR move
like that they feel that they can grow
their brand this is my conspiracy theory
I'm not saying I'm right I think the NFL
resents soccer the
worldwide in the UFC that started well
after them that also went global I think
they want to go global and I think
they've reached the max of amount of
sports fans so now they're trying to
grow their brand through caring
everybody's trying to show how much they
care or maybe it's a symptom of this
[ __ ] social media craziness where
everybody's like I don't know just going
nuts screaming and yelling at people
that they try to get out in front of it
and care about every cause that's out
there I have no [ __ ] idea but all I
know is I went to that game you know
going alright let me kill a day here and
forget that how much I'm missing my way
from my kid and I went there and it's
just like wow I guess the good thing was
I realized I don't have a lot I don't
have my troubles aren't as big as other
people's troubles but jesus [ __ ]
christ
and it felt how about you just pick one
pick one I'll you know the Fred Sox
always had the Jimmy fun you know they
had that it was that was it that was I
mean Jesus it was [ __ ] unreal
so anyways having said that you got to
go to the sting you got to go to this
daddy
alright but I would before you go to the
Falcons Stadium I would recommend you
watch Raising Arizona watch something
really funny get yourself in a really
elevated mood because they are gonna
bring you down
they are gonna bring you [ __ ] down
Jesus Christ well you know I'm the only
thing they think well you know and plus
it's also like what they choose to care
about is really [ __ ] like planned out
too like I'm waiting for one of those
NFL teams to bring out a bunch of
[ __ ] recovered heroin addicts that
got addicted through pain pills that
they got through the pharmaceutical
industry that is allegedly basically
synthetic heroin dealers why don't they
show that oh that's right because
pharmaceutical companies advertise on
those network then I could have show
that [ __ ] they're not gonna bite the
hand that feeds they're not gonna go
well why do people keep getting cancer
why is cancer through the [ __ ] roof
let's look at pesticides let's look at
what we're doing to
food supplies stay away from that stay
away from that pig on the military big
on the military to the point literally
of like I felt in a way that I was sort
of in like a Clockwork Orange and they
should have just had my eyes taped open
as they're selling me you know our
foreign policy like squirting tears into
my eyes it's just like you know it's
like guys what you're getting involved
with is way more complex than a football
game ok so just keep it simple stupid as
people have always told me so anyways
that was my experience overall it was a
great experience
I feel bad that I left the [ __ ] game
my mother always taught me never to
leave the game and I left and the
Dolphins came back in one and oh by the
way he was another loud thing any time
it was third down this is [ __ ]
hilarious any time was third down this
[ __ ] lunatic would just go
[Music]
to get the crowd like amped up and it's
just like dude I have a flat-screen TV
in front of me that is easily two and a
half times the size of my [ __ ] house
and it says third and two I can see it I
don't know but having said all that I'm
gonna give a shout out here to the
whoever the [ __ ] designed that [ __ ]
Stadium it is unbelievable it's gorgeous
and the college Super Bowl is there this
year she want to blow some [ __ ] money
and the Super Bowl is gonna be there
next year it's [ __ ] amazing it's
amazing in the NFL cares you know it's
another great one is Ford Ford Motor
Company they got a tie out there where
they go 100% of the proceeds go to fight
cancer which is great because a lot of
times it's a portion of the proceeds and
they keep a lot of it so I will commend
Ford for that but what's hilarious is
their website is something like Ford
cares calm it's like well let's play I'm
glad you care about that because you
certainly didn't give a [ __ ] where you
put the gas tank in the Pinto in the
Crown Vic did you anyways alright that's
it I'm done with my sports rants here
but uh thank you to the NFL and thank
you to the world of college sports you
guys got me through this [ __ ] weekend
the loneliness thank you to the new
punchline in Atlanta I got to do a spot
there last night and the Laughing Skull
down the street I've been having a great
time trying to stay shop with my act and
I guys I can't tell you the name I don't
know what I can I can't talk about the
movie that I'm in but I think I think
this one's going to be a [ __ ] good
one dude I am like really excited
looking at all of like the shots that
the direct I only say the director's
name because I never know what the [ __ ]
you can't say and can't say but the
[ __ ] shots that I've been seeing it's
literally I'm sitting like dude I'm
gonna be [ __ ] in this thing now watch
they're gonna cut my cut my part out
[Music]
when am I gonna learn to keep my [ __ ]
mouth shut all right you know what let's
let's do a little advertising here all
right what do we got here me undies
everybody me on DS owe me undies stop
showing people die in the nude dude do
it me undies me undies I'm at a football
game why am i crying I get dead people
have [ __ ] cancer people die in wars
don't wear fur can I just watch this
[ __ ] game you NFL greedy [ __ ] stop
acting like you care all right me undies
makes underneath your butt will be proud
to wear and check this out I'm not the
only one who loves me undies listen to
what my longtime listener and me undies
enthusiast George has to say a note from
George n/a Bill burr listener and me
undies fan what [ __ ] big brothers
[ __ ] is this I've never met this guy
anyways this guy said and there's no
last name how do we know this person
exists George and George non-existent I
decided to try out me undies because I
love bill burns me undies jingles I
smile every time he sings it somehow I
feel like they cleaned this up I smile
I bet he really said I like the way he
sings the [ __ ] songs do it I [ __ ]
laugh Mike balls off then they clean it
all up I smile every time he sings it
second two three Atlanta although it's
so easy to skip ads in a podcast I
always listen to bills reads and I'm so
glad me undies has stuck with them I've
been it's been probably two years since
I first bought a pair of me undies and
now I have a monthly subscription
because they are that comfortable I
swear to god this is their copy
this isn't me doing the like the
Atlantic South Atlanta Falcons things
like look at me hooking up a widow look
at me look how much my listeners love my
reads anyone's before me undies I used
to buy the 3-pack of underwear at retail
stores dude this is so edited there's no
way this was written this perfectly
until I realized that I wanted to treat
my junk there we go maybe it's trim to
something more comfortable and that
starts with a great pair of me undies
cradling my family jewels yeah that was
totally rewritten anyways to get 20% off
the softest most cradling jewel
underwear you could ever get and socks
you will ever own alright your feet will
be happy your balls would be happy and
your knees will be jealous free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee go to my
undies calm / bird that's my undies calm
/ bird
oh look who's here everybody Dollar
Shave Club dude dude everyone knows that
Dollar Shave Club ships amazing razors
for a few bucks kid what you might not
[ __ ] know is Dollar Shave Club has
products for pretty much every [ __ ]
thing you need in the bathroom body wash
shampoo hair gel lip balm [ __ ]
everything - you want to do a bump they
got a little dollar shape [ __ ]
cocaine spunk
if you're sick of a nonsense at the
store this Stila I one-two-three FOA
let's all go to the stillwe now is the
time to try out Dollar Shave Club for a
limited time Dollar Shave Club is
basically giving away their [ __ ] shower
shave stat is set to new members
sure shave static it to new members for
only $5 this starter set features their
executive razor and three trial size
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay so fresh it's so
clean boo boo boo boo boo boo boo look
at my [ __ ] nuts so fresh and so clean
in your first box you will receive their
shave butter body wash in one white
Chinese
jolly says like my love to wipe my booty
butt butt wipes you will also receive
their executive razor which includes
their premium weighty
handle and full cassette of cartridges
after the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks
a month this offer is exclusively
available at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / Dollar
Shave club's high quality products will
have you covered from face cheeks to
butt cheeks alright what do I got here
stamps.com stamps save you time and
money which you can use to grow your
business I can mail any letter any
package using just my computer and
printer and the mailman picks it up
avoid the hassle to the of the post
office and mail everything from
postcards to envelope envelopes to
package packages domestic or
international create your stamps
accountant minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print and mail and yet
done doed unlike the post office stamps
calm never closes print postage for
lettuce and or packages at your
convenience 24 7 keywords descriptors
[ __ ] I guess I'm supposed to say it's
convenient easy reliable and flexible
just like dead hoe down the street I use
stamps come because I don't know it's
[ __ ] easy I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure
out how to do it so can you and right
now you too can enjoy the stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without a long-term
commitment
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
birth at stamps.com and tuber stamps
calm never go to the post office again
all right
hey guess what I started watching
yesterday on Netflix I watched I watched
the first episode of narcos and it's
funny I tried to watch it the first time
and I don't know
I think the subtitles I got intimidated
because in the beginning there's this
they have this whole [ __ ] thing about
magical mysticism or some [ __ ] like
that and it's on the screen whatever the
paragraph is before that it goes by too
[ __ ] quick I can't read it and then
I'm just like ok this is gonna be the
pace of the reading I'm not gonna be
able to keep up with it well anyways I'm
lonely on the road I finally figured out
my netflix account it's [ __ ]
hilarious I got a show on Netflix and I
never watch it because I just I don't
know I just I don't interact well with
computers and all of this [ __ ] and then
once there's passwords I'm gonna forget
the password and then I'm gonna say
emailing my password and then somehow
it's gonna end up in my junk folder and
I won't be able to find it I just
figured you know [ __ ] it I'll just put
on me-tv and watch the Rockford Files
right well I finally figured it out and
I watched the first episode of narcos
and I'm 100% in what a goddamn show also
by the way the producers of the show
whatever the production company whatever
you say is Goemon which also does f is
for family I'm [ __ ] greater thing so
anyways when I watched that first
[ __ ] episode when he's sitting there
talking to those army guys and starts
naming their names
when pablo escobar's doing that and he
starts you know just letting him know
that he knows all of their families
members and like basically you know
without saying and something Bad's gonna
happen to him I still don't understand
why they just didn't take a gun and blow
his [ __ ] brains out there's no
loyalty in in that world once you
[ __ ] killed him then all then they
would they you cut the head off the
snake I know I'm over simplifying this
but I'm just saying this if there's any
DEA agents that are listening here if he
just blew his [ __ ] brains out right
then and there wouldn't all the other
gangsters underneath him wanted them be
the next Pablo Escobar's and then they
would start fighting with each other
wouldn't that happen and then they would
have to establish then they would have
to pay up they'd have to start all over
again like hey we had a deal with Pablo
he paid us off you didn't you know
wouldn't start all over again and then
they wouldn't have time to come after
your family I know I know I probably
totally [ __ ] over simplified that
[ __ ] thing tonight all right well how
much time do I have left here Oh Billy's
gotta hit the [ __ ] treadmill all
right keep his little [ __ ]
you know I haven't been boozing I've
been doing alright I haven't been doing
the greatest I've been [ __ ] I'm not
gonna lie to ya I'm in a [ __ ] mild
depression right now and uh but I'm
gonna see my my wife and my daughter
this week hopefully I'm somehow I'm
gonna I'm gonna get them out here all
right okay let's let's read some of the
[ __ ] oh wait a minute get in all
things Comedy Festival podcast read
that's right I'm doing my first live
Monday morning podcast this could be a
total [ __ ] train wreck no matter what
it's gonna be exciting we're having our
first all things comedy festival at the
end of the month October 26 through the
29th in Phoenix Arizona I'll be there
recording my first ever live Monday
morning podcast the great legendary Doug
Stanhope he's doing his podcast at the
Orpheum Theater Bert Kreischer
Ari Shaffir and the crab feast are also
on the lineup we're taking over downtown
Phoenix with the pop-up podcast studio
and the whole network is gonna be there
if you're in the Phoenix area come and
hang out with us go to all things calm
be calm get your tickets absolutely I'm
gonna be walking around [ __ ] shaking
hands kissing babies right doing public
service announcements on a on a giant
flat-screen TV reminding you that people
still get tuberculosis anything I can do
to depress you at our podcast now I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna do that
afterwards I'll do a meet Greek at the
end of the [ __ ] you know at the end
of the the mmm podcast whatever the live
[ __ ] thing you know I'll do all of
that [ __ ] unless I have a really bad
show and then I'll just go in the back
and cry all right let's get to the
questions here all right bill did
everyone know about Harvey Weinstein and
then parenthesis from a lady all right I
don't know why yet let me know is from a
woman okay hey Bill I'm a big fan of
your podcast and your show I saw in
Montreal earlier this year was epic
seeing a master at work as a beautiful
thing
you buttered me up you buttered me up I
have a lot of respect for you as a
straight forward guy look so this person
is brilliant she's going you know you're
a [ __ ] brilliant at what you do I
know that you never lie this is great
this is the way you ask a question if
you want to get an honest answer you're
one of the few I'll believe
unequivocally on this subject do you
think everyone in Hollywood knew about
Harvey Weinstein I can totally
understand how no one spoke out until
now he was [ __ ] scary and clearly had
the press in his pocket I'd like to
think I would have spoken out but
honestly I probably would have put my
[ __ ] life and career on the line with
little chance of taking him down
I just wish all the stars feigning shock
would just be honest and admit they knew
they didn't have the balls parentheses
or were too smart to step up would love
to hear near his thoughts on this so
would i but she's not here
congratulations on your amazing daughter
love hearing about you being a dad go
[ __ ] yourself all right first of all
thank you for talking to me as if I'm on
the big star level and I know what all
of them think I gotta be honest with you
I didn't know a [ __ ] thing about that
guy other than he had a lot of hit
movies
I came up as a stand-up comedian and
have risen to the having a vulgar
animated show on Netflix that's that's
the level I got to so I've done some
movies with some pretty big people but
his name never came up so if I had to
guess I I imagine a lot of people knew
that he [ __ ] around on his wife this
is all speculation I have no one but I
don't know
I think the women that he did it to
obviously you know allegedly you got to
say a legend now trying to get sued here
and still all alleged he has not been
convicted of anything the 58 people that
came out with the same [ __ ] story
it's all alleged I'd have to think that
they knew and then their friends would
know but how far it goes from that it's
it's it's I don't know I have no idea i
ago be honest with you we were in
between takes and on the movie and we've
shooting in this [ __ ] really cool
[ __ ] motel man I feel like I was in a
Coen Brothers movie so one of the rooms
we had was like the little green room
and they were they the story was on and
these women were coming forward and like
my mouth was literally a gape listening
to it why can't I be honest all I can
speak for me I can't [ __ ] believe
somebody could do that and get away with
it for that [ __ ] lie I mean the the
tape of that [ __ ] woman in how that
isn't enough I guess cuz he never said
yes I grabbed your boob I think he just
keeps going like I understand just come
inside scum I I'm used to this I'm used
to this none of that is an admission all
right no more just cause you're used to
this like I don't know I just got me
it's the most disgusting [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard in my life and if this
guy is as guilty as he looks
I'm worried that he's not gonna go to
jail because I don't know what evidence
there is and in the the statute of
limitations I you know you go back
decades with this [ __ ] I don't know how
it [ __ ] works but in a perfect world
they take him out to the desert and they
put to bite his [ __ ] ear I mean if
he's guilty if he's innocent
and I think I just [ __ ] my whole
career
[Laughter]
I have I have no idea I don't know who
knew what or whatever but I will tell
you I've been enjoying watching Fox News
having a field day with this trashing
Hollywood and you know given that guy
who was in the [ __ ] hot tub with the
thirteen-year-old girls who now hides
out in France giving him an award and
all that [ __ ] I love watching them
called Hollywood out I love watching
Hannity calling out the hypocrisy of
Hollywood you know trashing Donald Trump
for what the [ __ ] he's doing while that
shit's going on in their own town and
then all the while Hannity never
bringing up Bill O'Reilly while saying
that the friend what the [ __ ] is that
guy always forget his name
the French dude there whatever the guy
had now true France or whatever saying
and they gave this guy an award
afterwards and it's just like yeah and
you had Bill O'Reilly on your show
afterward so everybody is like I don't
know it's just such a [ __ ] amazing
time for that [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
complaining about the [ __ ] electoral
college while the Democratic Party went
to court it admitted that Bernie Sanders
got more votes but they colluded with
Hillary's you know campaign to be like
no you give us the best shot so we're
gonna pick you [ __ ] what the people say
I don't know I don't [ __ ] know and
then me saying that I [ __ ] hate
listen to people to talk politics and
then Here I am talking it yeah I have no
idea who knew what but I would
definitely say that you know the same
way like Fox News there's no [ __ ] way
they didn't know that Bill O'Reilly was
settling out of court in these [ __ ]
things you know this same way that
there's no way at the Weinstein Company
they didn't know something was amiss
I just don't I doubt I'd be honest with
you I am as shocked as anybody else I
just don't [ __ ] get it I don't I
don't understand it's it's just one of
the worst [ __ ] things I don't I have
no I don't to make jokes it's just one
of those disgusting [ __ ] things I've
ever heard and I don't want to pay
attention to the story because I don't
think he's going to go to jail and
listening to his comments he's the
typical piece of [ __ ] that does stuff
like that where he actually feels like
the victim you know I mean he's making
it about himself and how bad he feels
you know [ __ ] the victims you know
whatever the alleged victims would I
don't know [ __ ] them I don't know
what people knew but somebody knew
something and they should have [ __ ]
said something
anyways all right [ __ ] neighbor
threatening our dogs Jesus Christ all
right dear Billy butter tits hey I'm in
good shape right now by the way could
you guys just insulting you know Billy
how about Billy chiseled uh L buy no
chest you know something like that
I'm not chisel whatever I'm a lady lady
you wrote into my [ __ ] podcast and I
love you I'm a lady
in my 20 Glade 20s here in the Southeast
United States and I have an issue with
an older male neighbor okay but brief is
possible why am I doing this accent this
[ __ ] keeps coming on my property my
property and letting our dogs out of the
fence oh my god yeah yeah I I you need
to beat this guy in the bottom of his
feet don't do that by the way I don't
condone that violence is never an answer
we live next door to a busy road and I
hate to think what would happen if
someone came speeding down and hit one
of my dogs I have a big yard so he has
to come over into our property to open
the gate he waits until we leave to do
it it is easy go down to the spice shop
and get some cameras because some of our
neighbors snitched on he's an old white
trash dude that sits on his porch
smoking all day and he claims that our
dog
bark 24/7 they don't and the rest of the
neighbors have said they don't hear the
barking or when they do it's minimal
alright this is what I would do I would
get a I would get a lock on my fence
okay that he can't get past and then I
would go down to the spice shop and get
some cameras and then what I would also
do is let him know I would write a
letter and say that that's what you've
done okay just so because God forbid he
jumps over the fence throws your dogs
over and then they get hit and died you
know going okay it died and you gonna be
like all right when I caught the guy but
one of your dogs had to die what you
really want to do is just make prevent
this guy from doing it so let him know
that you know what he's doing that
you've taken these measures and then
maybe he will [ __ ] off because you know
it wants to see a dog die and then an
old guy go to jail or whatever just stay
on your porch field alright buddy get
him a pair of [ __ ] wireless
headphones you know so he can listen to
Bob adobo baybeh dabba doo buh doo buh
buh when he's [ __ ] headphones anyways
he goes my question is what the hell do
I just what she says my question is what
the hell do I do I've started locking
the gate so that shouldn't be a problem
anymore but what if this [ __ ] tries
to poison them or something now that's
where the cameras come in I'm probably
being paranoid but I'm pissed off I also
have a temper which doesn't help what do
I do bill now you're asking a guy who
has a temper uh boo mmediately suggest
you beat the bottom of the guys feet I
heard you talk about dealing with old
people neighbors and I'd really like
your advice thank you go [ __ ] yourself
yeah he's an old guy you know you know I
would just I would send a letter over
there and say I apologize if you find my
dog's annoying other neighbors say they
don't bark that bad
here's a pair of [ __ ] ear plugs and
some old man [ __ ] I don't know what
you give him give him some brats or some
[ __ ] we are now locking the fence so you
can no longer go in there and I also
have a camera set up okay I don't want
to you know I would just do that
whatever the [ __ ] I said earlier I would
do that
and every time you see me even if he
tells you go [ __ ] yourself just smile
and wave and just tell them it's nice to
see you I hope you have a wonderful day
I would just do that alright and then if
you have a house party I would fight him
over and just try to kill him with
kindness rather than beating the bottom
of his feet
alright dating in Asia Asia Asia oh this
is interesting I never even I never
heard about his dear Billy me undie
stains yeah I like that one good for you
all right
I've been living in Asia for the last
four years and dating has been tricky
Asian girls are beautiful kind and much
more giving in bed than their white
counterparts I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means
I'm certainly punching above my weight
class here
alright you punching these women I think
the better thing is saying that you out
kicked your coverage and having
relationships slash one-night stands
with the much higher quality of girl
then when I was back in the US dude this
is the deal you're over there and you
have an accent okay that's it
same way if you come over here if you
have a [ __ ] accent the women like it
does that work with Asian guys if you
come over here and you have an accent
with Asian women I have no [ __ ] idea
anyways however the biggest problem is
they are boring most spend their whole
life studying until they are 26 then
they work insane hours at work and they
live with their parents until they get
married not to mention that my sense of
humor can be totally lost on someone who
speaks English as a second or third
language yeah well dude you're on the
other side of the world things are going
to be different here I seem to be stuck
between beautiful boring Asian girls and
the typical basic white girl I'd
apologize for the sweeping
generalizations but you do it all the
time do I do it like that what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] Q do can you own your [ __ ] Innes
and that [ __ ] get yet you [ __ ]
[ __ ] stench on me
I know I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know
you you know point it out Oh boohoo I'm
on the other side of the world [ __ ] a
bunch of hot asian girls you got a girl
that was way too good for you so I'd
love to hear what you think all right I
agree with that thanks and go have a
wonderful day I live in Korea and I love
it didn't want to talk [ __ ] well dude
you're either gonna have to accept that
those are your options or move out of
there I don't know what to tell you do
you want the entire country to change
because you are there it sounds like you
there's a bunch of smart women over
there that something's nothin they're
perfect right they're educated they're
working their asses off the [ __ ] that
there's a bunch of animals in the rack
well what is the problem
[Music]
I don't know fine I don't know I would
start dating a prostitute over there if
you want a little more excitement
sounds like you live in the dream over
there buddy if I was you I would try to
appreciate what you have I mean I don't
I mean that's kind of perfect what she
[ __ ] blows your mind in bed and then
goes off and goes studies and then you
can sit down and watch the game I don't
know I don't know I don't know exactly
what else you want from him but uh of
all the problems to have in the world
certainly after all the problems that I
learned in the world in the first
[ __ ] seven minutes of that Falcons
game I don't I really don't have any
[ __ ] sympathy for you all right
heckled by veteran comedian as [ __ ]
lace hello Billy bald foreskin
hey after about two months ago I don't
know if they're making fun of my dick
there or what my head looks like but uh
either way it's funny about two months
ago I gave the open mic night a try oh
he heckled you as an open mic her that's
that's [ __ ] that good I prepared for
it for a while and finally worked up the
nerve to do it had material had some
semblance semblance of a planned attempt
I get about four minutes into it and I'm
getting laughs not a lot but some then a
bunch of smiles all right good for you
plus even the beginning all it's about
it's just having the balls to go up
there when they call your name it has
nothing to do with how well you do
anyway so I was confident and busted out
a joke that was a little racy but
nothing mean-spirited no one left oh
well I moved on a few days go by and I'm
getting hate on Facebook for the joke
from a comedian that has been working
the scenes for longer than I've been
alive oh Jesus Jesus really comic on
comic violence ah you hate to see it I
take what he says his wisdom but he
tells me that you shouldn't ever say
anything on stage you don't believe in
wait a minute
well now wait I mean you saying you're
getting hate on face but this guy is
basically giving you advice and being
heckled heckled is you're it's
interrupting a live performance you
don't get heckled on Facebook anyone
they say the comedian heckled the crowd
the crowd is not giving a performance
I called [ __ ] on that and always
thought as a comedian you get to push
the envelope
some because when it's all said and done
as long as you weren't hateful for the
sake of hate you're good anyways I have
had the nerve to go back on stage out of
the fear of getting trashed on Facebook
anyways love the podcast hope you come
to Memphis soon and go make love to
yourself also I can't get hard please
fix this with magic all right first of
all I don't know what you said I'd have
to know the joke that you said I know
how you feel about the joke I know how
the other comic feels about the joke but
it just seems like the comic is giving
you some advice there I don't know how
hard the person went personally I
wouldn't do that but you sound way more
seasoned than someone who just did it
for the first time wait a minute I
opened my I gave up my could try a pair
of prepared for it for a while Yatta
Yatta yeah I get my four minutes into it
getting last and he did the joke that
didn't go well
I mean I don't know dude I don't know I
mean I wouldn't say that to an open mic
her I also don't know what you said and
it doesn't sound it just sounds like
he's giving you an advice I can tell you
this right now if you're gonna let one
[ __ ] person and some [ __ ] on
Facebook make it not go back onstage
then then this guy did you a favor
because you got to be weights you got to
be way tougher than that because if you
think this is the first [ __ ] time
like it's just you know when I was
sitting in that motel we were shooting
the other day I walked in and I just
laughed I was like all these places
smell the same and one of the actors
asked me he goes what's the worst gig
you ever had and I thought about it for
a second and then I just laughed and I
was just like that is just too big a
subject for me to pick any one gig I
mean you literally have to go like worst
gig without a microphone worst gig in a
cafeteria where they didn't know that
there was a show
nooner worse you know I am I gonna get
this [ __ ] kicked out of me worst gig
where I didn't get paid worst gig where
the [ __ ] middle AK was a former
headliner and he did 45 to an hour in
front of me and tried to burn out the
crowd you got white crowds you got black
crowds you got college crowds cruise
ships I mean it's just it's just and I
you know what's funny is I haven't
forgot any of them but I can't remember
any of them either they just all are
this giant ball of honey hate and
humiliation and that's what you signing
up for and I'm not trying to discourage
you here and what it is is what you need
right now rather than writing to me is
you need to go to more open mics and
what's going to happen is you're gonna
get comedian friends from your
graduation class right and what you do
how you get through all of that was I
used to call up you know the comics that
I started out with like if I had a
member Patrice having some brutal show
in front of a bunch of cops when he
started up and he hate his balls so bad
that he called me up and through talking
to me he was able to laugh about it then
I was laughing about it and you know
then when I bond all the [ __ ] time I
would call him up you tell the stories
then what becomes as in other comics
trying to top your story about wha well
the worst gig that they ever [ __ ] had
and that's what it just starts to become
as you're going through it you just get
season and then you're just literally on
stage going through some of the worst
humiliation of your life while thinking
I can't wait to tell this to my buddy
when I get home or what I mean just
don't let this [ __ ] guy discourage
you [ __ ] shake it off
you know you got to be like a relief
pitcher you [ __ ] gave up all run give
me another ball I'm gonna get I'm gonna
funk coming right back what they hate
you got to be like that I'm not saying
that comic is right or wrong because I
don't know what you said he evidently
felt it was serious enough to reach out
to you on Facebook but I it's not
something I would have done I don't try
to be the comedy [ __ ] cop here all
right
so good luck with you sir all right this
joke bartnick says take your balls out
of your parse it [ __ ] get back on
stage all right good luck to you all
right caught wife shoplifting dear bill
bill 'no Saurus rex okay my wife and i
have been together for 13 years and
married for about half that time
basically we are best friends with a
romantic relationship congratulations
things have recently started getting
even better for us all of a sudden I've
noticed all these extra knickknacks
around the house I got my first job at a
as a university professor and she got a
job in administration at the same
University oh my god she's shoplifting
I believe our relationship is as strong
as it is because I can trust her with my
life I think that just changed last
night after getting home from the mall I
found her taking makeup out of her purse
the same makeup that she refused to buy
because it was too expensive her
reaction told me I wasn't supposed to
see that she had it I confronted her
about the potential shoplifting the
confrontation resulted in a long
argument one that swung from denial to
anger at me to crying and then back to
anger she could never prove that she
paid for it giving a reaction in the
circumstances I am as confident as one
can be that she shoplifted absolutely
she would have just produced the receipt
[Music]
trust me
dog Trust is important to me bill
my wife is beautiful and she's
constantly approached by men I need to
trust that she will stay loyal to our
relationship her shoplifting and then so
brazenly lying to me about it puts
everything into doubt for me how is this
risk worth her career or our
relationship is shoplifting not that big
a deal could this also increase the
likelihood that she is dishonest in
other areas of our relationship am I
crazy
I will be listening to your advice by
the way you killed it in Toronto thank
you ah dude yeah I mean I don't know
where I think it's all of those things I
think it it might not be that big a deal
or it could be the tip of an iceberg
I have no idea I have no idea but this
is like the beginning of a great movie
and I'm sorry that you're starring in it
[Music]
like this is like some Alfred Hitchcock
[ __ ] like rear-window except you're in
the apartment with the murderer
potentially or you know it just sort of
ends like that War of the Worlds
anticlimactic
I don't know but
yeah like do you pursue it do you pursue
it because I'm always about like when
you feel [ __ ] like that sit down with
them and just say look I'm not saying
you're a bad person I'm just saying how
what you did make makes me feel alright
and then tell her everything that you
just said to me however you could also
be pulling some threads here and and the
whole thing comes to crashing it I don't
[ __ ] you know what do you know what I
would do dude [ __ ] this you know
something this is what women do when
they're feeling something they [ __ ]
they sit you down
[Music]
[ __ ] her tears [ __ ] her anger [ __ ] this
you got to validate what you're feeling
you see I like this is what men do when
they get a relationship you treat your
wife your your your girlfriend like a
ticking time bomb because they so much
this guy's right I do generalize a lot
on the [ __ ] podcast don't they
[ __ ] they control the relationship
with their emotions and then it's all
subtly tied to special teams which is
your [ __ ] you know sex life and if
they're in a [ __ ] bad mood about you
you're not gonna have any [ __ ] sex
it's [ __ ] ridiculous but that's how it
works
so but [ __ ] that dude if this is what
you're feeling and all of that [ __ ]
you're supposed to sit on it [ __ ] that
what do you think your wife would do you
don't think she would do that you don't
think she would start snooping on your
facebook I don't know I'm not saying
don't [ __ ] snoop on the Facebook what
I'm saying is is what you should do is
you should tell her I don't know what to
what to do here if you [ __ ] do a
stakeout if you start [ __ ]
oh man that's creepy
because then if you're [ __ ] wrong now
don't do that cuz then if you're [ __ ]
wrong and she catches you spying on her
then then she has the upper then then
you become wrong because you caught her
shoplifting yeah I would sit her down
and just say listen okay I'm not saying
you're you're a bad person or anything
I'm just telling you how I feel seeing
you shoplift and then lie to me about it
and do it if she starts crying or she
gets angry [ __ ] that she's being a
[ __ ] baby and she's manipulating him
and then I would also sit there and I if
she does that again I would say and now
your inability in a mature way to handle
what it is that I'm saying to you and
you let her get his [ __ ] angry as she
wants to get and it's like be like
you're getting angry at me I didn't
steal anything I didn't lie about it
okay I'm just letting you know what how
this is making me feeling we can totally
get past this if you're gonna be an
adult about this and sit down own up to
what you did and talk me through this oh
is she gonna get [ __ ] mad at you and
you know what [ __ ] her okay cuz this is
what they'll do dis is exact [ __ ]
thing that she'd do to you
and I by no means [ __ ] super imposing
all the [ __ ] issues I have with women
on you in your relationship I absolutely
a.m. but that's what the [ __ ] I would do
and you know something what else do you
want from me that's all I can do is tell
you what the [ __ ] I would do that that
is what I would do
alright it wasn't fair for her to put
you in that position and now for you to
sit there walking around carrying this
[ __ ] stress so I would address it
with her alright and there you go that
is the podcast an hour and 20 minutes
Jesus you know I should do these once a
month the [ __ ]
the Billy red rag podcast you know once
a month I'm just going through my cycle
there was a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] moaning
and complaining on this one but uh I
just feel like for me
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on you on Thursday all righty that's
it oh hey by the way congratulations to
the Vegas [ __ ] gold Knights you know
what I mean you beat my Bruins last
night I saw we subhan was in [ __ ] net
playing goddamn great I know he was in
our farm system that's P K's brother I
forget his first name
it's so [ __ ] great and the fans are
going crazy it's so awesome Vegas is
gonna be a huge goddamn head and I can't
wait to go to a game out there and their
color isn't all about their colors but I
actually like that logo I didn't notice
that you know there's a little V there
in the [ __ ] helmet I think that's
kind of cool
Vegas night helmet oh that's clever all
right let's go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk
to you on Thursday